Right now, at this very moment you have a
virus controlling your brain.
No just kidding, well sort of.
Hello again, Julia here for Dnews.
Fun fact: Our DNA contains a lot of virus
DNA.
Over one hundred thousand pieces of it!
Over 8% of our DNA is made up of so-called
En-dodge-e-nus retroviruses.
And a recent study by Lund University in Sweden
indicates that just such a virus might be
responsible for our super powered homosapien
brains.
This study found that when these virus DNA
bits are activated, they also activate nearby
genes.
Meaning, old viruses control our brains, well,
that there are some old viruses in our DNA
that control when certain genes get switched
on and off.
The researchers say this suggests that retroviruses
have played an important role in the development
of a complex brain.
Perhaps they are one of the reasons brain
cells are so complicated and versatile, giving
humans the evolutionary advantage of intelligence.
So how did viruses get in our DNA?
Well, you can think of them like fossils.
Once upon a time, millions of years ago, one
of our ancestors got a virus.
Maybe a cold, maybe something else.
Back then, the virus was just a normal retrovirus,
hanging out in a host cell.
What makes retroviruses unique, is how they
reproduce.
Retrovirus carry their genetic material in
RNA.
To make more copies of itself, it makes a
DNA copy of its genes and inserts it into
a host’s DNA.
The host cell then reads the DNA with the
viral insert and is tricked into making more
copies of the virus.
But by a stroke of luck, this particular virus
happened to infect a sperm or egg cell, then
when the baby developed from that cell, it
carried that virus DNA in every cell in its
body, and when it in turn reproduced, passed
that bit of DNA on to its baby. and so and
so forth for millions of years.
These bits of viral DNA become so well integrated
into the host’s DNA, they become almost
harmless.
The viruses mutate to the point they can’t
function.
They lose their ability to break out of a
cell and infect a new one, eventually, they
can only make copies of themselves which get
inserted back into the host cell.
Multiple copies of the virus gene can wind
up strewn throughout our genome.
Since this has been going on for quite a while,
humans and other mammals have defenses against
these DNA intruders, proteins that keep the
virus from replicating.
It’s thought that most of the time this
bit of virus DNA in our genome doesn’t do
anything.
So they become what scientists consider “junk
DNA”
While most of these viral fossils are just
DNA duds, sometimes they are harmful.
They’ve been linked to some brain disorders,
like schizophrenia and even might cause certain
cancers.
Sometimes, they are kind of good.
Some domesticated viral DNA functions like
a gene regulator, they can tell which genes
to turn on and off.
On occasion the virus DNA is hijacked and
put to good use.
We owe a lot of our success to virus DNA - and
when I saw “our” I mean mammals.
On at least 6 different occasions, virus DNA
led to the development of placenta in various
mammalian species, a huge evolutionary step.
This viral protein, called syncytin, used
to help host cells bind together so a virus
could spread more easily.
Now this protein is responsible for the lining
in the placenta that helps aid nutrient exchange
between the mother and developing fetus and
protects the fetus from the mom’s immune
system.
Studies show that when these viral genes matter
a whole lot, when they are turned off in mice,
embryos don’t survive.
So we’re a little bit viral..
That’s kind of cool, and researchers think
this latest study could lead to more research
on genetic links in certain diseases of the
brain.
Most of the research on genetic factors for
diseases focus on just two percent of the
human genome.
Adding the possibility of a viral related
genetic link opens a whole new range of possibilities
for scientists.
so what do you think of our viral inheritance?
Cool?
Weird?
Both?
Sound off in the comments below.
and for more cool and weird science, check
out DNews everyday.